Nach der entdeckung der gravitationswellen geht es jetzt richtig los auch das thema
Habt ihr euch wieder über whatsapp gewünscht schon albert einstein hatte die gravitationswellen, im jahr
1916 vorhergesagt doch bis sie zum ersten mal nachgelesen werden sollten dauerte es ganze
100 jahre warum verformen gravitationswellen das weltall und wie konnte man
Sie nach einem jahrhundert endlich aufspüren und was passiert damit in zukunft jetzt in klicks und science fiction hat sich willkommen
Ja und wenn er auch über whatsapp und die anderen messenger mitmachen wollt, am ende
Des videos erfragt wie das funktioniert heute mal wieder fix sein süppchen aus juli
2017 war es endlich soweit der nobelpreis für physik ging an drei
gravitationswellen forscher aus den usa
Denn, sie hatten jeweils mit ihren experimenten und mit ihrer grundlagenforschung zum ersten mal den nachweis von gravitationswellen
erbracht rainer weiss kippt form und barry bärisch haben tatsächlich gezeigt
Einstand hatte recht übrigens gibt sein könnte als executive producer von intercell
Und wirklich die messung von gravitationswellen ist nicht nur für die
Physik welt eine sensation dazu, rainer weis ein gebürtiger deutscher ich betrachte das mehr als eine
sache die die arbeit von 1000 menschen anerkennt und
tatsächlich an diesem thema waren bis zu diesem zeitpunkt sicherlich
unzählige forscherinnen und forscher weltweit dran ich hätte sogar das weitaus mehr als
1000 forscherinnen und forscher dabei besonders spannend ist die persönliche geschichte von rainer weiss der tatsächlich
Selbst diesen ja einen unfassbar wichtigen augenblick verpasst hat am 14 september
2015 0 54 51 amerikanischer ortszeit lage erstens noch, im bett und war zweitens
Im urlaub weit weg von seinen beiden kilometer langen detektoren die plötzlich erzielten erst dachte
er nur dass es ein fehler war
Ein tolles signal von seinem forschungsteam um zu testen ob die datenauswertung auf sauber arbeitet doch dann war klar dass das system
Nach einem update für solch einen fehlalarm noch gar nicht bereit war und das war der große moment der von jetzt auf gleich
alles veränderte nach
jahrzehntelanger suche hatten sich
gravitationswellen es lassen ausgelöst durch den
zusammenschluss von zwei schwarzen löchern wie immer in der wissenschaft ist solch eine entdeckung noch deutlich mehr wert wenn sie wiederholt werden kann und tatsächlich
auch folgende messungen
bestätigten den nachhall solcher kollisionen
dass dafür den nobelpreis fertig war ja eigentlich reine formsache zu seiner großartigen karriere sagt reiter weiß heute wir haben nicht groß über
gravitationswellen nachgedacht die technik war faszinierend wir hatten solchen spaß dabei die zum funktionieren zu bringen ein bisschen wie kinder in einem großen sandkasten
Ja es werden ja bei einem gravitationswellen den sektor die interferenzen zwischen zwei
im 90 grad winkel zueinander verlaufenden laserstrahlen gemessen wenn sie durch eine gravitationswellen
durchlaufen ändert sich jeweils die raumzeit der beiden strahlen unterschiedlich wenn sie dann miteinander abgeglichen
Bilden sie interferenz angefangen hat also alles mit der relativitätstheorie von albert einstein indem, er die
gravitationswellen beschrieben hatte demnach produzieren alle beschleunigten körper
gravitationswellen doch in den meisten fällen sind sie viel zu schwach um sie nachzuweisen angefangen beim start eines autos bis hin zu einer sternexplosion
Am ende ihrer lebenszeit die entstehenden gravitationsfeld stauchen und strecken raum und zeit etwa so wie ein stein
Den man ins wasser wirft und der die wasseroberfläche kreuze dazu muss man wissen dass
gravitation ein relativistische effekte zugeschrieben in der allgemeinen relativitätstheorie
große massen
Verzerren raum und zeit unsere erde zum beispiel hinterlässt eine beule im raum und zeit und in diese bäume fallen wir auf die erde wir
Werden also nicht durch eine kraft auf die erde gezogen sondern durch die vertiefung die sie in der raumzeit
ferne wenn also massen sich bewegen oder
kollidieren dann erzeugen sie dadurch keine delle sondern eben wählen aber vor allem große objekt
geben alle erzeugen starke gravitationsfeld schwarze löcher und neutronensterne
Wenn solche massen schnell genug beschleunigt werden wird die raumzeit so stark durch wirbelt dass die gravitationswellen auch noch in größerer entfernung
Aufzuspüren sind so wie eben bei der kollision der beiden schwarzen löcher, im september
2015 wenn sich die wellen
Im weltall ausbreiten wird alles was sie passieren in einer richtung gedehnt und einer anderen richtung zusammengedrückt
Eben wie bei wellen doch selbst wenn die gravitationswellen sehr stark sind verformen sie das weltall nur minimal
der effekt ist eben nur extrem schwer messbar einstein dachte jedenfalls damals
im leben nicht daran dass man irgendwann in der lage sein
Die witzigen veränderung zum essen die diese welt gehören in diesem punkt ja
Da sollte er sich dann doch getäuscht haben der direktor des laser interferometer
gravitationswellen
observatoriums liga in den usa der
13 manche jedenfalls nach dem ersten nachweis vor 400 jahren hatte galileo ein teleskop auf den himmel gerichtet
Ich glaube wir tun heute etwas ähnlich wichtiges wir eröffnen eine neue ära denn durch die detektion von gravitationswellen
können wir jetzt ganz andere dinge
Im weltall beobachten die uns bisher verborgen geblieben sind und schon bald wird noch ein viel
empfindlichere instrument dafür in betrieb genommen das wird uns wahrscheinlich
täglich neue gravitationswellen melden die europäische weltraumagentur esa plant nämlich den gravitationswellen
detektor lisa
Im weltraum er soll zwischen erde und sonne gebaut werden und zwar an dem punkt an dem sich die kavitation
Der beiden gestirne auf der erste test hatte wurde bereits erfolgreich
ausgesetzt das laser interferometer space antenna system kurz leiser wird auf drei satelliten bestehen jeweils
2,5 millionen kilometer voneinander entfernt sind beim lego league die länge der arme bei 4 kilometer es wird also rund
600.000 mal empfindlicher sein bei einer entfernung von 2,5 millionen kilometer ist dieser
gravitationswellen detector eben viel empfindlicher dass sich die raumzeit auf solange entfernung
Deutlicher aus der start des systems ist für 2034 vorgesehen
Da können wir also extrem gespannt sein wer als erstes neues dazu
Zu allen anderen dem erfahren wollt dann endet meine telefonnummer hierbei rezept oder den anderen messengern wie instagram
facebook messenger oder telegramm dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen andern vom neuesten video täglich
Garantiert ihr könnt doch direkt über mich in der redaktion von links und mitmachen und mitbestimmen was hier wirklich passiert und zur begrüßung gibt es
Noch ein kleines goodie einfach hier klicken und natürlich nicht das abo mit der
Vergessen hier geht es weiter fraglich mit stephen hawkings letzte arbeit veröffentlicht ansonsten bis dann
bleibt